but also I suppose it's because with
your kids you could spoil them you have
to try and be strict with them yeah it's
tough like because you know as you doing
alright you want to give them the life
that you didn't have you know so you
know but you have to be strict because
you don't want to turn them into
children that you hated when you were a
child to be those kids so it's tough you
know and I remember taking my daughter
to get new school shoes so I took all
fine I thought if you've done this gap
you've taken all of them out just by
yourself like an idiot took them all out
we've gone to buy a new school shoes and
it's a busy day in the department store
and that most of them been fine and then
just one daughter's just kicking off
just going for it right and I've not got
the skills that your parents had cuz you
know laws have changed
[Applause]
find always you've got all that talks
from like a children's TV presenter when
you get all you have to do so she's
being a nightmare I just couldn't
wrangle ERK and I just could work it out
and and and and what happens is the
other thing with when you've got many
children is that your other children
start being good really good but not
good because they want to be good they
want to be good to highlight how bad the
bad ones being good out with other
you're like yeah but it's not coming
from a good place in the end I have to
do that thing that parents do sometimes
where where you go overboard with the
punishment so like when they're not
eating the dinner the you know you're
like right then you'll never eat again
you know it's my daughter she was like I
want these they're being spoiled and I
said right then you'll have no shoes so
I got shoes for the other kids and I've
got these like four pairs of shoes and
none for her and I'm very very rare that
I stand by a punishment right and even
but then I've sent them upstairs the
wrath way down before they've got there
you know so I'm in this queue and and my
daughter's gone from being naughty to
turn in their waterworks on and of
course it's a new crowd around them so
these people just think she's like
Cinderella like not getting any shoes
don't you
and she goes and then she said the worst
thing and as parents you'll you'll feel
this right it's the worst thing that
anyone can say to her I won't use
Chile's ACS she said daddy and I went
what she said that's all these people
looking like daddy why do you make the
rest of the world laugh what'd you make
me cry
[Applause]
you got three pairs of shoes okay
[Music]
you